Sim.
Então, avançando, os bits
e os qubits serão os elementos computacionais fundamentais
com os quais podemos enfrentar
problemas complexos no mundo
então vamos tentar entender a diferença entre eles
e de onde vem o poder dos qubits
se olharmos para o lado esquerdo
há uma forma de descrever, e vamos usar esses diagramas
ao longo da apresentação para
ilustrar o poder — estamos vendo um círculo
e dois pontos; quando o ponto está no polo norte
é o zero; quando está no polo sul, é o um
esse é o estado de um bit clássico; agora um qubit é a
unidade de informação no mundo quântico
e aqui temos a esfera como imagem
a esfera é zero e um
e podemos tê-los nesse estado de superposição
temos um recurso especial disponível para nós
não só podemos posicioná-los nessa esfera
mas imagine que cada um deles
é como uma pequena lua
que está nessa esfera e podemos girar a lua
então aqui você está vendo que
a esfera inferior foi girada levemente
por isso você vê um pouco de azul
e rosa, e poderíamos girá-la completamente
aqui está uma rotação de cento e oitenta graus
então temos essa noção de fase que a computação quântica nos oferece
três superpoderes que se manifestam nos qubits
são os poderes da superposição
o poder da interferência
e o poder do entrelaçamento
então vamos explorar esses princípios — o princípio da superposição é na verdade
bem simples de entender
então a estrela no lado esquerdo
temos o polo norte zero ou polo sul um
e se somarmos esses dois estados
agora temos um qubit em superposição que tem tanto
zero quanto um simultaneamente, polo norte
e polo sul; agora o diagrama da direita é o mesmo
mas agora vamos fazer um pequeno truque
vamos aplicar um gate, um quantum gate
no que fizemos aqui é lembrar
que podemos mudar agora, podemos
girar essas pequenas luas, certo
então giramos cento
e oitenta graus e agora temos um
então quando fazemos a soma de zero mais um, chegamos
a um estado de superposição
mas note que é diferente
e no da esquerda ainda temos
zero e um, mas agora com um estado girado
para o um; isso vai ser muito poderoso
para então aproveitar uma segunda coisa realmente interessante, que é
o princípio da interferência
e essa não é uma operação que podemos realizar no mundo clássico
de bits; então aqui neste exemplo temos
um zero e um no lado esquerdo, mais
esse novo estado que criamos
que também é zero e um
mas com essa lua girada; quando fazemos isso agora
podemos interferir esses dois estados
e note que algo bem interessante aconteceu
cancelamos o estado um
e ficamos com o estado zero
fizemos isso porque interferimos os estados
então a próxima oportunidade que temos agora
é quantos estados podemos criar
e a coisa linda na computação quântica é que podemos criar um número
exponencial de estados; então vamos olhar para um sistema que tem
cinco qubits; neste caso estamos representando esses qubits
como qubits independentes, certo, você os está vendo à esquerda
zeros e uns, e eles estão sendo multiplicados; temos cinco
deles, então o número de estados que podemos criar ou
que o computador quântico representa nessa esfera à direita
é dois elevado à
potência do número de qubits que temos; neste caso são cinco
então dois elevado à quinta potência são trinta e dois estados
então estamos vendo trinta e duas dessas pequenas luas
note que nesse caso não incorporamos
nenhuma fase — todas são rosa; o aspecto poderoso de
usar essa propriedade chamada entrelaçamento no mundo quântico
é que podemos criar agora estados
como o representado à direita
onde temos essas combinações de rosa
e azul, e esse estado não pode ser descrito
como o produto independente
desses cinco qubits; neste caso
como temos trinta e dois estados
o que isso nos diz é algo muito profundo